so when the trailer to this movie says
James Cameron presents why they got Ally
sanctum ultimately I should read James
Cameron's cameras present which oh good
it's not like we haven't seen it like
150 times this year yeah this year 2011
so all in all underneath all the layers
sanctum is pretty much a disaster movie
yes when you have a movie in which
people need to survive the elements
earth fire wind or water it's a disaster
movie I don't care if it takes place in
a cave so in this particular disaster
movie there's a group that's exploring
these underground caves and then it
starts raining in the underground rivers
and start overflowing the place starts
flooding and now we have our survival
disaster movie now I will say that of
all the 3d movies I've seen this is the
one that I will say if you're gonna see
the movie you see in 3d whether or not
it's worth the price different story the
movies pretty much a 3d showcase and the
shots look really cool but there sees
with their rappelling or parachuting
down into the hole in the ground so it
looks like a big Sarlacc pit or
something without the beak and it looks
really awesome which is really funny
because National Geographic in the movie
is supposedly there to document their
findings or whatever and I was just
thinking I would rather watch that I'd
rather watch National Geographic
presents a 3d movie or video on
underground caves that would be sweet
but instead we get disaster movie so the
basic concept is after everything starts
flooding the entrance is blocked so they
have to press on into the cave and the
uncharted territories and hope it comes
out the other side think of it like an
MMO you have to go into that new zone
that you don't know anything about and
just imagine your life depends on it
it's kind of like Posada it reminded me
of Poseidon in a cave with worse actors
and crappier characters like they have
mr. fantastic from Fantastic Four maybe
I'm just slow on the pick up but I never
really noticed how crappy of an actor
the guy actually is in fact when
characters start dying you don't care
about any of them at all you're like are
either dead one less person have to
worry about there is one character I
thought was cool he's your basic really
hardcore experienced guy who's like this
is life and death this can kill you a
Nobby
but no matter how many times he says it
it's almost like the characters really
don't grasp but their lives hang in the
balance there's like alright yeah let's
just get through the cave yeah nothing
it's like Six Flags Water Works but more
fun and the editing was really weird
like there's this one part where they
have to get across this big hole then
disaster hit so half the group is here
and half the groups there and they're
divided by this huge hole in the next
scene they're all together just hanging
out I guess they got across I like
the concept of the movie I like the
scenery but it's like the movie was
written by a guy who does a lot of cave
diving so he's heard a lot of stories
probably seen a couple things and he was
like I want me to make a movie about
this he could only be written right by a
guy who's been there or at least heard
from a guy who knows a guy who's been
there and so now we have this movie
there were no really cool scenes in the
movie that really stood out to me the
one scene the coolest scene in the movie
was actually in the trailer see what the
dudes underwater and he's like breathing
in the bubbles that are on the ceiling
they shouldn't showed that at all I was
like The Dark Knight trailer showing the
magic trick so on the basis our
assumption that if you're hammered you
can at least laugh at the acting or
throw up because of the 3d this movie
might be a good time if you're drunk
yeah party the 3d makes the movie it
didn't make the movie good if you didn't
like Poseidon - don't watch this maybe
we'll have better luck with the roommate
but if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more